a 44 year old man is accused of crashing
his pickup truck as you could see right
into a dotty's casino in north las vegas
this morning
why
police say david holmes was driving
drunk it happened while people were
inside hector joining us live near kerry
in north las vegas actor
we're finding out nobody was hurt here
that is the good news no one was hurt
the manager confirming everyone walked
out without a scratch but he was not
able to confirm exactly how many people
were inside as you can see they're still
working to fix the mess left behind
[Music]
at around 3 45 friday morning this
pickup truck slammed into a north las
vegas studies casino hitting nearly
everything in its way bassey washington
lives nearby
when you hear what happened
all you could think of just the people
almost going there almost every let's
say three times out a week thankfully no
one was hurt even after the truck went
all the way inside near north las vegas
and kerry i showed washington the
pictures sent to us by north las vegas
police oh it came close to the bar for
it that area right there it's a lot of
people that be right there though a lot
police identified the 44 year old driver
as david holmes first of all he should
not have been able to drive police agree
holmes was arrested on the scene and
booked on a number of traffic complaints
dui driving without a license no
insurance operating an unregistered
vehicle and failure to stay in a lane i
still hate that something happened but
they need to put here to put a burial in
front of the door
and that's what they're trying to do
right now trying to fix side of the wall
here the manager also saying to us that
they are hoping and working to reopen as
soon as possible in north las vegas
hector mejia live local now